[Music]  Justin Bieber's new song is good like  really good I feel like the response has  been pretty awesome the song is called  friends it's a collab with a blood pop  and it's definitely about a breakup  [Music]  Justin worked with Julia Michaels and  Justin Tranter on the song there Selena  Gomez's friends too and fans are  wondering if it's about her but I'm  thinking no mostly because when Justin  released sorry people thought the same  thing  and he told ET this it's not necessarily  to any girl or to one girl I didn't  write it in with having anything in mind  what we do know for sure it's a bob  that's what it's all about for sure I've  been non-stop listening to it  [Music]  you